el cielo se tornó rojo en Hawaii
mientras cenizas y escombros salían a la
superficie un hecho histórico el mauna
loa entró en erupción es el volcán más
grande en activo y llevaba dormido desde
1984 su periodo de calma más largo desde
que hay registros aunque no ha habido
evacuaciones los científicos son
prudentes no queremos intentar adivinar
el volcán tenemos que dejar que
realmente nos muestre lo que va a hacer
y luego informaremos a la gente de lo
que está sucediendo lo antes posible por
el momento se han abierto dos refugios
como medida de precaución pero no se
cree que haya peligro ni para locales ni
para turistas puesto que la mitad de las
erupciones registradas se limitaron a la
Cumbre sin embargo se está actuando con
prevención ya saben estamos muy
atrasados bueno estábamos muy atrasados
para una erupción del mauna loa y por
eso nos hemos estado preparando
el mauna loa es uno de los cinco
volcanes que forman la isla de Hawai
Ojalá es el único considerado inactivo
son conocidos por su gran tamaño mauna
loa mide 4.169 metros
[Música]
son producidos estos volcanes muy
grandes y anchos que se conocen como
volcanes escudo y eso se debe a que la
composición del magma que entra en
erupción allí es muy fluido
desde hace unas semanas se han activado
las alarmas después de una serie de
temblores algunos ciudadanos están
tomando medidas de prevención pero
acostumbrados a vivir bajo amenaza
aceptan que la diosa de los volcanes
pele fluirá donde y cuando quiera